Trey,
my daddy Joe Rogan podcast by night all
day round cake man goes to the body to
it was a domination,
like a total complete domination and
was a strong favorite in this fight.
I Air Max Holloway.
Well although number 10 what's up?
So let's build the guy up
and that's what I think this
guy's a killer someday in the future.
I think that's a legit fight and I
think that's an interesting fight.
I'm like the flooring.
Callaway is a bad motherfucker.
Max Holloway is a bad motherfucker.
It's a really interesting fight.
I agree with you man.
Well Hey,
they made Ferguson could be beneficial
for interim title.
Everybody getting titles every fight now
from now on will be an interim title.
Damn it.
That'd be nice.
Wait,
Khabib is,
I'm sorry they made what?
21st century.
Yeah,
but they made it as more title,
which I don't understand.
Wow.
That's super confusing.
It's very confusing because
Connor just won the title.
Uh,
see I think this is more of a sign that
comms is going to fight Floyd next cause
he's probably talking to Dana like
you ain't see me anytime soon.
Son or it's more of a sign
that they wanted to have a
pay per view card that was
stacked with championship fights.
But if you keep doing interim titles,
people are like,
all right,
we get it.
Everyone's a fucking wheelchair to
Congress about to have a baby because his
wife's about to have baby.
Correct.
So that's going to be take some time.
Well maybe he's not.
I mean he's richer than lots of guys.
That's true.
I mean he's like,
listen,
I don't want to go through training camp
right now and experienced this first
kid had a baby.
Don't get from training camp.
Yeah.
I mean it's a fucking man.
Bad asses.
Yoyo Rodriguez.
Unbelievable.
That's the coming out party
folks Bj had on his back though.
Or is it a product of Bj being basically
a heavy bag in there and I love Bj.
It's that,
but it's also,
look,
I think Bj,
when he was 10 years younger,
it would have been a tougher
fight for you out here for sure.
What's interesting for sure,
way tougher fight
style.
Who fucking knows.
This is the problem though,
is that it's not just a
matter of Bj being a legend.
Bj being an all time great
to division world champion,
bad motherfucker without a doubt,
but his style is a boxing based attack
and then a vicious ground and pound and
vicious,
a top game submission game.
Bj is not a guy who submits guys off
his back and Bj is not necessarily a guy
who kicks that much.
So yeah,
I hear who's an outstanding kicker,
the best kickers.
He has just this huge advantage.
Do you know what it's
like if you check window,
if you had a guy who said
and you box a little bit,
if you had a guy that said,
hey,
let's spar,
you can kick and I'll just box.
You'd be like,
well good luck with all that.
Can I kick your legs?
And he'd be like,
yeah.
I'd be like,
Oh,
well,
well you just,
you're going to have a terrible afternoon.
Yeah.
Terrible.
Came over,
right?
Yeah.
You're fucked because
didn't Bj fight didn't,
am I crazy?
Or did he fight a cheetah?
Cheetah.
Oh,
Christ as a heavyweight.
It's called the Rock and
the rumble on the rock.
The Rock in Hawaii.
No,
no.
He fought Leonardo in Japan
and rumble on the rock.
He fought Carlos Con.
No,
he didn't find Carlos Condit
Lialda and rumble on the rock.
He fought go me.
He beat the fuck out of gummy memory.
Brought Gomi over to rumble.
Beat the shit out of
him and strangle them.
You spot somebody else.
I think you find in a,
I'm going to say k one because he
fought Duane Ludwig and k one as well.
Yeah,
I thought he fought in rumble.
The Rock.
That's crazy.
Hmm.
You might be right.
I don't know you that Jamie.
How powerful fucking tie and pocket
handkerchief for Tyron Woodley.
I know all you gotta.
You gotta fucking kind of
feel like you're half in less.
George Saint Pierre
comes out of retirement.
Then you make an exception.
But since joy,
oh look at this.
Just as horrible to watch,
man.
He's just taking that
left kick to the head.
Oh,
the wheel kick.
I mean this is like right away.
Early in the fight.
He's getting staggered.
He's getting his legs
kicked out for longest.
Wme Boys made this macho man,
that three 60 round kick to the night
jumping front kick behind ditch.
Oh my God.
To what I hear Rodriguez first,
Brian or take is a fun one.
Look Yahya Rodriguez versus
anyone as a front one.
I mean the kids 24 years old.
Who the fuck knows what happens with ya?
I hear,
yeah,
you're might not even stay at 45.
He might be stepping up to
55 in the next few years.
Might be the Mexican economy.
He might be the motherfucker.
Take us.
Take us 45 isn't ranked number.
He's uh,
he's right.
The head of hair.
He's number nine.
Dude.
When you say Bj Penn get rocked like that.
You see the legs give out like
on the k one heroes for me.
Where's that at?
Longest active wind streak in
the featherweight division.
Max Holloway giant Joe.
You're right.
Yeah,
I think it was k one,
right?
Yeah.
And before that it was
a rumble on the rocks.
And who do you find rumble on the
rocks back up a little bit there.
UFC go down way down.
Keep going.
Nope,
that's fine.
Where are you going?
Me.
He fought tag annoyed.
You [inaudible] fight someone else.
Gracie.
[inaudible]
That's right.
And that was a decision,
right?
That was kind of a boring fight,
if I remember correctly.
Powerful Larry landless referee
having seen what kind of did too.
Uh,
Eddie Alvarez.
What?
What is your,
what is your take on Alvarez?
I mean that Conor,
Khabib,
does it matter?
That does that he has to fight Tony.
He's got a fight town.
That's a,
you can't just dismiss now you're done.
[inaudible] peep guts this.
Fuck.
You're right.
I forgot about that.
That's very,
and you can't ever use MMA math.
Here's why.
Rhonda Rousey submit some
Cat Zingano in 14 seconds.
Cats and Ganos stops Amanda
Nunez and the third round,
Amanda Nunez Destroys Ronda
Rousey and 48 seconds never,
ever wasn't worth based on
what that matchup styles.
It's one on one.
It's like when you using that translator
thing that I told you about and you
read things correctly,
Ferguson is,
the floor is nasty.
He's such a bad ass.
How,
what a great picture,
man.
That guy is awesome.
He's so fucking good,
man.
He's the best boss logic to that guy.
Yeah,
man.
Okay.